welcome everyone welcome back welcome
back for your reunions and I see a
couple of I see plenty of alumni but I
see a couple of future students welcome
to you also so my name is Krishna Reggie
Gopal I'm speaking with you today
wearing my dean for digital learning hat
I'm also a professor of physics at MIT
I've been dean for digital learning for
almost two years I've been professor of
physics for 22 years now so what I'll be
talking about is open learning open
learning is an office at MIT and it's
also something we do in something we
believe in so I went to start by putting
opening MIT learning in a historical
context this is something that MIT has
been doing since its founding MIT really
has been sharing its education where the
world for a very long time the
technologies that we use to do this have
changed over time but the idea that MIT
shares its education shares its
pedagogical methods shares its learning
shares its perspectives with the world
goes back to its founding William Barton
Rogers and his colleagues in the 8th who
found it on my teen 1861 Barton Rogers
built an education based around the idea
of men's at manis mind at hand mind in
hand one of the things that he meant was
lab classes William Barton Rogers
actually invented the idea of a lab
class before Rogers in eighteen the
1860s the idea that as a student at a
university you would actually have your
hands on test tubes or do it.make doing
experiments in a lab didn't exist he
invented this idea and his colleagues
really it was in four departments
pioneered laboratory education lab
classes one department was called
mecan't the one lab was called mechanics
and physics sort of the foundations of
what you we now do in the physics
department and the mechanic
during department one was architecture
one was metallurgy which is the
predecessor to today's material science
department and one was chemistry and in
each of those he and his colleagues
figured out what a lab class was how you
could actually teach young
undergraduates in a way that involved
them doing experiments and not just
reading books and they didn't just do it
for MIT
Edward Pickering who was one of the
first professors at MIT with Rogers he
wrote a guide to the laboratory class
that he invented design and that guide
was used that many many other
universities in the 1870s and 1880s so
by the time you got to the 1880s mi
t--'s men's at man s idea had been
copied far and wide the places like
Princeton Yale Harvard Columbia had
copied this idea and so this is my first
example I'll also mention that not far
from here if you go up the stairs a
little that way little that way you'll
get to junior lab and what junior lab is
where we teach lab classes in physics
now and on the wall and junior lab
there's a plaque commemorating the fact
that William Barton Rogers invented
junior lab and that that was the first
laboratory class ever so another example
hundred years later
Sputnik happened and many people at that
time felt that the way that the high
schools in the United States taught
physics and math was not as good as it
could be but a group of people at MIT
decided to do something about it the
group led by Jerrold Zacharias it was a
physics professor at the time created
something called physical science Study
Committee so what were their
technologies well they wrote textbooks
they made film strips this is this is
the late 50s early 60s were all through
the 60s they made film strips they made
kits of kits of apparatus and they
created an organization called EDC et
see was its initial role was to spread
physical science study committee
curriculum to high schools all around
the country and then around the world
they were successful when I was a high
school student in the early 80s in
suburban North Toronto all my physics
curriculum was from pssc I had no idea
that it came from MIT because it wasn't
branded MIT it was called physical
science Study Committee what is this
orange textbook a bunch of film strips
anytime the teacher was out they showed
us a filmstrip and that was when I was
in high school and then in 1997 I
arrived at MIT as a faculty member and I
actually met some of the professors who
might seen on those film strips at that
time in 1997 when I arrived the people
I'm thinking of were already and I had
either recently retired or were soon to
retire but I remembered their younger
selves from the film strips that they
had made in the 1960s which I had seen
as a high school student so different
technology than we are using today in
open learning but same idea so the the
part of this history that I will
actually talk about starts in 2001 with
MIT is OpenCourseWare and in 2012 with
MIT X and these last two and much more
are now part of what we call the office
of open learning but the this notion of
transforming teaching and learning at
MIT and around the globe through
innovative use of digital technologies
that's our mission statement if you take
out the word digital it's William Barton
Rogers mission statement so the office
has multiple moving parts I'm going to
focus on the ones in that oval so this
is sort of instead of showing you an org
chart this is a diagram equate
describing all the different parts in
the office of open learning this
gearwheel represents the parts of the
office where we produce online content
and share it with the world in multiple
different ways I'm going to talk about
open courseware MITx micro masters and
what we do on campus residential
education so let me on this slide
mention the things that I won't talk
about
so these two here ex-pro is online
professional ed courses mit has been
doing professional IDI for more than 70
years through X Pro we do online
professional ed courses so these are
sort of think of it as executive
education boot camps are similar in
spirit but they're not entirely online
the idea of a boot camp is you start
with a with an online course and after
taking the online course you apply and
are admitted to an intense one week
in-person boot camp MIT has now run
about twenty five of them a few of them
have been here but they've been all over
the world also we've run boot camps in
Tokyo and in Turkey and in South America
and in Europe and the tipic there been a
probably almost a dozen topics by now
but the boot camps that we have gotten
best at are those which are built around
innovation and entrepreneurship about a
subject so you might have innovation and
entrepreneurship about Internet of
Things and the idea of this is after
again these are you these are working
professionals think executive education
but with this boot camp mode at the end
of the week you leave with a business
plan that's the idea of the boot camp
this test tube here this is the research
component of our office the integrated
learning initiative is a research
initiative it leads catalyzes funs
convenes research on learning at scales
ranging from let's say one brain up to a
school district so it includes
economists who are studying how school
districts work and don't work it
includes neuro scientists who are
studying what happens in your brain when
you learn something new Jay well this is
the Jameel world education lab this
could be a talk in and of itself it's a
it's a great new part of MIT the way to
think of this is I'll be describing to
you how we engage with individual
learners but it's also powerful to
engage with institutions the Jameel
world education lab is sort of these
arrows represent vectors it's a way for
us to infect other
institutions with our way of thinking
about education whether our way of
thinking about higher ed our way of
thinking about workplace learning or a
way of thinking about k12 I'm actually
not going to describe it in full but
they're out that one point much later
I'll mention an example and then at any
given moment our office incubates new
things I'll give you one example I I
think virtual reality and augmented
reality are not yet it's not yet true
that you walk into any classroom at MIT
and what you see is students with VR
goggles on learning through virtual
reality simulations that's not true but
I will be very surprised if by ten years
from now there aren't many classes at
MIT where that happens for a part of the
time and so we have a research oriented
center Center for advanced virtuality
led by Fox Harrell which is leading
leading our efforts to make sure that as
virtual reality and augmented reality
play a more important role in education
we're on the cutting edge that's an
example of something that we're
incubating which we don't yet know how
exactly it will fit into what we're
doing on campus or around the world but
it's it's clearly something we should be
paying attention to so let me start with
the the first of these topic
parts of the office that's in the Oval
and that's OpenCourseWare this is the
oldest part of the office of open
learning it was founded in 2001 18 years
old and what is open courseware open
courseware is material from our
on-campus courses shared with the world
so as a faculty member I teach my class
that's the end of the semester I have my
problem sets my exams my curriculum Ike
my syllabus my reading list and if I
would like to I'll go to him he's
sitting right there and I'll give him my
stuff and put it and he'll he'll make it
an open courseware page we have now been
doing this for 18 years and we now have
materials from 2,450 MIT courses online
it's an extraordinary
open educational resource it has had
been visited about 300 million times in
18 years we don't know who those people
are there's no sign in so that that's
not 300 million unique visits but it's
been visited in fact now well over 300
million times in 18 years it gets about
two million visits a month it also has a
youtube OCW has a YouTube channel all of
the videos there are now several
thousand videos from more than 200
courses on the OCW site and we have all
of the OCW videos on a youtube channel
which this slide is about to be out of
date we're at like 1.98 million we are
very close to two million YouTube
subscribers and already even before we
cross two million the OCW is the largest
dot e-d-u channel on use on youtube I
think you will all understand that there
are more popular channels on YouTube
than this if you include everything on
YouTube but among channels that are dot
e-d-u ours has the most subscribers of
any I'll also mention the newest
substantial addition to OpenCourseWare
now about four or five years old is the
educator is educator resources we have
educator resources for about 200 of the
2000 courses the idea of educator
resources is Sarah Hansen who leads this
part of the OpenCourseWare project will
come to me the professor and say ok you
just gave me all your stuff but before
we put it online let me ask you how did
you use it in the classroom how did you
teach your class what you know what were
your expectations of the students coming
in what was your thinking behind how you
structured your syllabus and your
problem sets so she comes and interviews
me and she and Sarah then creates either
sort of a a a web page or perhaps she
interviews me with audio or she might
videotape the interview she she produces
something which is aimed at telling
other educators how they can use this
content that we are sharing so helping
educators to use our materials in their
classroom so starting in 2012
with the creation of the edx platform we
have been able to do more than course
materials we have really been able to
offer courses for the world so when we
build an online course we refer to those
as MITx courses so MIT X is the MIT
content the MIT courses and we share our
courses with the world on on the EDX
platform so MIT X is the content EDX is
the platform there are now 130
universities that are members of the EDX
consortium sharing their courses through
EDX our courses are MIT X so to give you
a sense of scale if you go to the EDX
platform and count mitx courses there's
more than 170 now that's by on-campus
counting a slight over count because
what we have done in many cases is to
take a one semester course on campus and
break it into two or three modules on a
tax so if you count equivalent MIT
courses it's 123 at the moment and we
have modules coming from 32 more MIT
courses in development right now these
courses come across comma come across
come from across the full breadth of MIT
29 departments all five schools and they
also span their whole range of levels at
which MIT does education we have many of
our core first-year subjects built out
as online courses so I know if I should
use numbers for the alumni in the room
you all remember the numbers I use
numbers or names so we have we have
online courses corresponding to 801 and
802 are two intro physics classes 1801
intro calculus 1803 differential
equations were building 1802
we have 700 intro biology 309 one intro
solid-state chemistry we're building 511
one which is the the more standard intro
to chemistry
am I forgetting microeconomics
14:01 another class at this level 600
intro computer science both both halves
of it those are all examples of intro
level first-year level classes that we
can that anyone in the world can now
experience the online version of we also
have many more advanced undergrad
classes you'll see an example in a
second we have lots of masters level
classes I'll talk more about that later
and we have very few PhD level classes
the PhD level classes typically reflect
the individual initiative of a faculty
member who really wanted to do something
really cool we have run our courses 506
times in the most recent year 111 course
runs 26 of which were new courses in 85
of which were courses we were running
for the second or more time the standard
numbers that everyone quotes are these 8
point 1 million registrants 3.7 million
unique learners you should ignore those
numbers the reason is that in the world
of online courses what is register mean
it means you clicked a button and then
you got counted ok it's the easiest
thing to count so everyone counts it if
I want to compare to Harvard this is
what I can compare so it we have to
count this I and I and I and I like to
show it because everyone is used to
seeing these kinds of numbers but when
you are exploring on EDX you probably
click on 10 courses before you pick one
that you would actually like to engage
with and so we prefer really to count
courses that our learners seriously
engage with and the phrase we use is
explored explored for us means you
watched at least half the videos and did
at least half the problems and we've had
700 85,000 people explore at least one
of our courses all of the learning in
our courses is open to anyone for free
if you wish to earn a certificate you
pay a small fee and at this point we
have had one hundred ninety four
thousand certificates earned our
learners come from all over the world
you're gonna see in a video in just a
second I get a little tiny little hint
of the kinds of things you see in our
courses but
they're much more than video the video
is actually the easy part where we have
invested in an enormous amount of
creativity and effort is in the
interactive online exercises really
trying to reproduce the MIT problem-set
experience online so well fair question
why why are we doing this so why are MIT
faculty building these online courses
the second bullet is the first one
you'll think of and it it's it's reached
bringing the best of MIT to the world
it's a it's it's part of the reason but
I want you what I think that's in terms
of if you ask me as Dean what are the
motivations of a faculty member who
walks in my office for the very first
time to have their first chat with me
about maybe getting involved in doing
this what are they thinking of it's more
likely that they're thinking about the
first bullet so a big part of why
faculty do this is that if you to build
online problems and to build segmented
videos of the type that we can assemble
into an online course these same digital
tools are now very very useful in
teaching MIT students we use them to
increase the free energy of students for
learning on campus for curricular
innovation and I'm going to spend about
10 minutes explaining this with a bunch
of examples um but just to give you some
numbers we have a private version of the
EDX platform just for MIT students it's
our private in-house copy of the
platform faculty can put they don't have
to build a whole course they can just
put one problem set on that platform and
we in the most recent academic year had
more than 10,000 course registrations of
MIT students on campus in classes that
we're using our private EDX platform so
MIT has about 4,000 undergrads and last
fall we had 6,000 we had 6,000 course
registrations in courses that we're
using our private EDX platform so this
has spread throughout how we teach on
campus and a big part of what I want to
do with the rest of the talk is to give
you a sense of the interplay between on
campus goals for building these tools
and world facing goals for building
these tools I will say that reputation
and impact is something we think about a
lot I think a substantial now way in
which MIT maintains its presence in the
world is its online presence and this is
certainly one of the motivations for why
we why we build these build these tools
and recruiting as of today more than a
quarter of the undergrads enrolled at
MIT enrolled in an MIT X online course
before they ever enrolled at MIT and by
the way mi t--'s admissions office
tracks what they call yield what yield
means is suppose MIT makes her an offer
a few years from now what's what what
are the probabilities that she will come
to MIT if MIT makes her an offer that's
called our yield and our yield is 90
something percent for those students who
have watched our online courses before
they apply and our overall yield is 70
something percent which is still very
high so this doesn't I'm not going to
claim causation it you can think about
what this means for yourself but it
certainly makes us think that we're
doing something that's relevant in terms
of maintaining mi t--'s reputation so
I'm gonna show a video this video was
made for a group of alumni not this
group of alumni so I'm a professor of
theoretical physics and I'm a member of
this MIT Center for Theoretical Physics
and we had our fiftieth birthday
less than a year ago and for our 50th
birthday celebration we brought back 50
years of alumni to MIT so 50 years of
theoretical physics alumni we had a big
celebration a lot of theoretical
physicists returned for that day and we
made a number of videos we made videos
about a variety of topics so one of them
was about digital learning so this is a
completely physics centered video this
this was made for an audience of physics
alumni and it's just as I'm telling you
what MIT is doing today this was us
telling our physics alumni what MIT
physicists had been doing in digital
learning so I apologize for the physics
of it but that's that was the context
and what I'd like you to hear is how
these faculty are thinking both about
the world and about MIT and let's let's
have a listen oops
sorry that didn't work so here we go
I've been a faculty member in the Center
for Theoretical Physics for almost half
of it's 50 years when I was offered the
opportunity to become mi t--'s new dean
for digital learning a big part of how I
thought about the role came from my
having watched the remarkable things
that my two CTP colleagues Ian and
Barton had been doing with digital
learning over the last few years
effective field theory is an important
advanced topic for graduate students
that is often not taught in a regular
course curriculum in effective field
theory we build at the quantum field
theory that is specially designed to
study physics at a particular distance
scale while systematically retaining
information that is needed for higher
precision my goal in designing the
online course a 20 FGX
was to take a unique special topics
course taught at MIT and make it
available to researchers and graduate
students from around the world since the
MIT course is not offered every year the
online version also provides a resource
for our graduate students to learn the
material in this way the online eft
course serves as a repository of
information about effective field theory
that can aid people's research in
high-energy physics nuclear physics and
other disciplines
I've always felt it's a privilege to be
able to teach quantum mechanics to young
enthusiastic students we at MIT are a
little different we give three
undergraduate courses in quantum
mechanics this gives our juniors and
seniors a very strong correlation that
allows them to do undergraduate research
very effectively our online efforts aim
to make the teaching of quantum
mechanics better at MIT and we also want
to share what we learn with the whole
wide world the technology is amazing we
can teach these courses without any
compromise the online courses are as
difficult and as challenging as the MIT
courses we teach this online grader is
quite amazing it allows you to check for
complicated formulas and even graphs of
functions we don't need anymore to have
multiple choice questions the problems
are sophisticated and address all kinds
of important issues
so it's official now our online course
8:05 one has become a permanent part of
the MIT curriculum we're very proud
about that Barton and Ian are two among
the growing number of MIT faculty who
are using these new tools to transform
how we teach our students on campus and
how we reach learners around the globe
on campus our MIT students love the
combination of first of all watching
Barton and IANS video segments wherever
they want whenever they want sometimes
they like to make the professors go a
little faster sometimes they need to see
something twice or three times they use
the rewind button
second of all the online problems which
give them instant feedback give them an
instant indication of whether they're on
the right track or not and third of all
after doing the online work coming to
class with the opportunity to ask
questions to discuss to engage in a
classroom his dynamics have been
transformed made much more interactive
by the fact that the students have done
the online work first and how cool is it
that Barton and Ian are at the same time
giving learners around the world a look
at how they teach quantum mechanics and
field theory putting their stamp on the
next generation and defining how quantum
mechanics an effective field theory are
taught and in fact understood far beyond
the CTP
so I see Nicole sitting in the back
there
Nicole was a physics major I don't know
that she was at the event but I will
guess that Nicole took 8:05 at some
point I don't I don't I won't ask her
who were professor was I've taught 805
but all Barton has taught 805 eNOS
taught 805 but in Nicole's day 805 was
only offered in the fall and that's not
because of anything other than the fact
that the physics department didn't have
the resources available to teach it in
fall and spring we now teach it in the
spring and the way we teach it in the
spring is that our students who take
8:05 in the spring take the online
version
Barton's online course plus they have
two hours a week of a recitation section
there's typically about 20 students who
do this so this is 20 students with an
my tea faculty member having an engaged
active discussion after they've done all
the online work and that now allows our
students who want to take 805 in the
spring to have an opportunity to do so
in this new way we also use the 8:05
content in the fall in the fall there
are lectures of the traditional type
often given by somebody else
not necessarily Barton and the students
can benefit from having Barton's
perspective in the online course
together with the lectures of whomever
is teaching it that fall
ian's course is an advanced PhD level
course and when he built the online
course at that time he had taught his
course on campus five times in 15 years
and he had taught 40 MIT PhD students
his perspective on quantum field theory
and in the first run of his course
eighty students finished it at the
online course and they were graduate
students from around the world the Ian
found the students for his online course
by sending out an email to physics
professors all around the world whom he
had an email list of and 80 PhD students
from around the world took the course to
the end learned learned Ian's
perspective on this advanced area of
research through this new method so Ian
basically in one go tripled his impact
on the future of theoretical physics
relative to what he had done in the
previous 15 years so this is another
kind of impact that we can have with
this technology at a much more advanced
level than the intro undergrad or
masters level courses that we have many
more of so if this were a different
audience I would now spend 10 minutes
talking about how you as faculty can
make a proposal to me and get a grant
and go build to go off and get our help
in building your course I won't do that
I won't describe our grant process
because I don't expect any of you are
about to make me a proposal but I will
we've been running of an internal MIT
grant process in spring of 2015 I'm
going to just sort of page
through the list of courses that we have
funded the development of since spring
of 15 and the reason I'm doing this is
just so you can see that they really do
span the breadth of MIT yes there you
see quantum mechanics in bartenbach but
you also see visualizing the philippines
with chris kappa zola who's a former
secretary of the faculty and one of our
great professors of history there you
see computational thinking for modeling
and simulation but you and engineering
the space shuttle but you also see world
music global rhythms let's see there's
some more quantum mechanics that's
Barton's third class there but then you
also see qualitative research methods
that Susan Silby she's a sociologist and
anthropologist teaching how to do social
science research via qualitative methods
including in particular interviews that
you can then code and analyze the
transcripts of so we have built a great
set of online courses that flow from
what we teach on campus there are many
more still to go our goal is to is to
offer a cross-section of the best of MIT
we will never have two thousand four
hundred and fifty online courses but we
could easily have twice as many as we do
now and still be building courses that
reflect things that we are very very
proud of and haven't yet gotten to so we
slept a lot of work to do a key part of
how we do this is a group of people
called the Digital Learning Lab I see
Mary Ellen there she is a member of the
Digital Learning Lab one of our leading
figures in digital learning in biology
at MIT so I'm gonna use Mary Ellen as an
example for what I'm going to say at MIT
if I as Dean went to the biology
professors and said let's say you're a
biology professor you wrote me a grant
proposal my Advisory Committee supported
it we're gonna build your biology class
and here's the person that's going to
help you do it
it's my staff I found them somehow they
work for me and this is the person that
will help you build a biology class that
will never work because you as a biology
professor will
this person that this Dean pic doesn't
know biology how did the Dean pick the
biologist and by the way that person
that the Dean is introducing me to is
not actually a biologist as far as I'm
concerned where'd that person come from
so instead the biology department hires
Mary Ellen and Mary Ellen sits in the
biology department and this year she
works with you and next year she works
with you and next year she works with
you over the course of multiple
semesters she will work with multiple
faculty on multiple courses in her
department helping the biology faculty
do things that catalyze improvements in
learning on campus and build online
courses for the world now if Mary Ellen
were isolated in biology
how would she learn how best to build an
online course she's a great biologist
but how is she going to learn how to
build online courses so what we do in my
in in my office is to convene the 25
Mary Ellen's from across MIT they're not
all Mary Ellen's there's only one Mary
Ellen Mary Ellen and her 25 colleagues
and to make sure so they meet across the
hall from my dean's office every second
Wednesday in the afternoon so the the
mechanical engineers and computer
scientists in the digital learning lab
can learn from Mary Ellen's experience
because they all know each other and so
they form a community of practice
advancing digital learning across MIT
but the key to this in our culture is
that Mary Ellen was hired by the biology
faculty as sits in the biology
department she's a lecturer in biology
she's respected by the biology faculty
and the same is true for the analogous
person in each of the other departments
where we have a Digital Learning Lab
presence this has really been key and so
one of the things that I do is to find
people to play this role in other in
departments that do not yet have a
Digital Learning Lab scientist in them
so let me turn now to how we're using
these tools to make MIT education on
campus for MIT students better as I
already mentioned I
9 percent of today's MIT undergrads have
taken at least one class that uses our
private version of the MIT X platform
and I will I think I've said actually
many of the things on this slide already
I'm gonna give examples in a second I
will just say that one of the things
that our residential group is it does is
to make to light boards available to
different places on campus you saw those
in the video many of you are wondering
how Barton and in learned to write like
da Vinci
they didn't ok Barton and Ian look
left-handed in those videos they're both
actually right-handed the software flips
you so if the light board it's an it's
it's a neat trick actually but the
software flip it's actually that's
actually very easy that's the easy part
the challenge of setting a light board
up is in fact getting the lighting right
so you don't see the glass but so we
have these light boards set up and
they're used for making out making
videos for online courses in that case
you probably plan ahead carefully maybe
you have a script you you you you're
trying to use this use this new mode in
the best possible way we also have
faculty who've gotten so used to this
now that they just run down and make a
video the light board in fact it's not
that far from here
suppose you're teaching in this room for
example and you finish your class and a
half an hour later you go damn I could
have explained that better there are
faculty now who when that happens and I
say when not if when that happens you
run down to the light board without a
2-3 minute video and what you say hey
you know here's a different way of
explaining something we did in class
today and you just do it quickly at the
light board and then you can have that
on the MIT X platform the private
version for your students by the evening
so faculty are using these tools on
campus in ways that require much less
polish than if you're making an online
course we have a website that you can
all look out called residential digital
innovations there are 59 little stories
many case study
on this web page describing 59 different
ways that MIT professors are using
digital learning tools to improve how we
teach on campus so this is MIT faculty
explaining to each other how to do
things better but we share this so that
I mean anyone can see what we're doing
there are 59 of them I'm not going to go
through 59 but they fall into several
groups and I'm gonna mention spend a few
minutes talking about the two biggest
groups so one big group goes by the
buzzword of flipping the classroom I
don't know how many of you have heard
this phrase I actually hate the phrase
because if if you hear oh we're gonna
flip the classroom I'm gonna flip my
class
that sounds easy right you go flip and
you're done
that's the wrong connotation because the
idea here is to take lecture content and
move that online by building segmented
videos with little problems interspersed
that basically allows students the
students of today who are used to
learning everything on YouTube anyway
speaking about my son's to learn you
know in a mode that they're used to to
learn the kinds of things online that
they would rather learn online okay now
you've opened up time in the classroom
and the key thing here is you have to as
a fat as that educator you have to ask
for what purpose what am I going to do
with the time I've freed up and
different professors are doing different
things some people are creating problem
solving instruction in the classroom so
in to give an example from 1805 this is
in 1805 classroom today what you see is
students learning how to solve problems
at the whiteboards with lots of
undergrad TA is helping them this used
to be a lecture class it used to be
taught in a room that looks like this
one instead now it's taught in a room
that looks like the one you see on the
screen but other people other faculty
are doing different things - just some
quotes from the students in 1805 the
students on the top the instructor on
the bottom the best quote actually as I
learned well by teaching others and what
really the key to what happens in this
classroom is the engage
that you get when you have students
teaching students whether it's Pierce
teaching peers or maybe it's a it's a
junior teaching of teaching uh sophomore
that to me is my favorite quote from
among these this is an example from the
humanities professor shigeru me again
why used to lecture in this class on
visualizing cultures and now he's built
an online course and he says that the
classroom time has the discussions
become much deeper because he doesn't
have to present the material in class
they get that from the online from the
online mode and so then they have a much
deeper what time for a much deeper
classroom discussion this is an
engineering class that Lorna Gibson
teaches and this was one where that she
pulled her students and the students
were actually very very happy with the
new mode of instruction a big part of
what they like is the immediate feedback
on problem sets which I'll come to in a
minute this is an example from economics
Esther Duflo used to lecture and now she
does case studies in the classroom
I mean case case studies are not some
case studies have been done in in many
educational contexts for many decades
but the point is that Esther wasn't
doing case studies she was doing giving
lectures and for her the fact that she
now had the videos and the creative self
graded problems online allowed her to do
something that was for her new namely to
do case they do they use the case study
method in the classroom so the second
bucket big bucket is problem sets so not
everyone is building Vidya is making
videos for their students a decent
fraction of what people do and it
doesn't involve video at all it may
involve the online problems that you
heard Barton's we Bach talked about in
the video and the reason for this is
first of all well let me say second of
all it frees up ta time if you if you
have either grad students or more
advanced undergrads as TAS having them
spend their time grading pencil and
paper problems is an incredible waste of
creative young people it's much better
to get them in the class
we're actually helping with teaching and
if you have the grading done
automatically by the EDX platform that
is frees up to a time as this slide says
that's the second reason the first
reason is the immediate feedback in the
old days when I was a student when I did
a problem set I'd write my answers out
on some paper hand them in ten days
later I'd get it back and someone had
graded them and I'd have some red X's
and if you ask the faculty why are we
doing this they say it's for the
learning we faculty say that problem
sets are all about learning they're not
about assessment we do assessment with
midterms and finals problem sets are not
about assessment they're what you need
to do to learn the material okay so
where's the learning if after the
problem set is graded the student gets
it back ten days later and never ever
looks at it again and so in this finance
class in this physics class and in many
others
our faculty are now giving our students
sophisticated online problems that are
automatically greatest you get immediate
feedback you learn did I do this right
or did I do this wrong and if you did it
wrong maybe that's set up to give you a
second chance and students are scoring
this very highly when surveyed about it
and faculty are very happy with this
because the faculty see more learning
happening as their consequence of doing
the problems this I already mentioned
last bucket and probably smallest at the
moment we don't have that many examples
of this but we have a few examples of
faculty using these tools to help MIT
students engage with the outside world
in new ways this is a use case that has
not yet been much developed and I think
it's caught it's it's a really good one
so this example Tom Koch and a former
chair of the faculty teaches an MBA
course on shaping the future of work and
he's now built an online course based on
his MBA course and he then has his MBA
students serve as TAS in the online
course so the MBA students from MIT meet
the people from unions and industries
out there Thomas an industrial relations
expert he when he runs his online course
he knows
people in all the union's of the United
States and in many of the industrial
many of the industry organizations also
and so he gets people in his online
course who are very different than MIT
MBAs and that's the point from Tom's
point of view tom says that is one of
his favorite comments from his MBA
students is that when they interacted
with the people online they realized
that they don't think like us and he
said that that was the point of building
the online course for him so what we're
doing is blended learning and this
phrase describes many things that we're
doing it has as many meanings as they're
create as there are creative educators
I've given you a bunch of different
examples at MIT many of us are
innovating and finding better ways to
blend online and face-to-face teaching
into the MIT education of today and once
we're doing that we can then open MIT
learning to the world because because
we're building these tools to help teach
students on campus better that means we
can then share the online part with the
world and so MIT X then is MIT quality
learning opportunities selected from
within what we teach at MIT so people at
MIT and elsewhere are thinking about
blended learning not just at the
course-by-course level or the problem
set by problems that level but at the
entire curriculum level and I'm gonna
give two examples from elsewhere and
then the best example from MIT so two
examples from elsewhere this is from
Uruguay you can't this is slide is not
so easy to read but this is an
educational curriculum for a group of
sixty students at Lu Tech University in
or why it's called programa and data
science this is their logo mi t--'s
Jamil World Education lab is helping
them to set this up so they have joined
J well become a member of J well and
then J well is helping them to set up
this new educational curriculum and what
does it consist of well it consists of
courses from MIT X but not just the way
we offer them to 785 thousand people
around the world because these Uruguayan
students are getting in effect an MIT TA
a answering their questions in a live
discussion forum more like a
videoconference okay so they have a
videoconference twice a week with a TA
from MIT and with a faculty member from
Uruguay so this is what the way that
these courses are being taught are much
more similar to the way that MIT
students are using the online content
online which is to say online content
supplemented with a real serious
in-depth discussion with an expert they
are also going to do courses from
Uruguayan universities and MIT the
Jameel World Education lab is running
three in-person workshops for them so
this then constitutes a blended
educational experience that will result
in a master's degree from the Uruguay
from who tech I'm sorry I forgot what
new tech stands for but it's the Uruguay
it could be the Uruguay Institute of
Technology but that's not exactly right
so second example from outside MIT this
is one that comes from San Jose San Jose
City College all credit to them ok this
we didn't help them do this we just
built the online courses that courses
that they use but they created this
curriculum
no no Jamil world education lab support
and what they did is they said well wait
a minute we're in San Jose we noticed
that there's this EDX thing and there's
great content on it from MIT and
Berkeley let's see how we can use it and
they this is their diagram it's very
complicated I love the fact that in
their diagram MIT exits in the middle
okay that's nice
we like that but this is this is their
curriculum this is for San Jose City
College which is a four-year college in
San Jose these are two MIT X courses
intro to computer science taught by Eric
Grimson and John Guttag this is a
Berkley class on data science I mean we
have classes on data science but they
they they pick the Berkeley one their
choice and a Microsoft class on
artificial intelligence a Microsoft
class on cloud computing San Jose City
College themself is teaching
entrepreneurs we have a class on
entrepreneurship but they decide to do
this themselves so these
these are the San Jose City College
educators looking at what's available
and putting together a curriculum for
San Jose City College students and to me
this is tremendous and the key by the
way for this working at San Jose City
College supports they their students are
all assigned to counselors and this San
Jose City College services is the key
the San Jose City College students are
not just left to take the online course
as independent learners they get support
from San Jose City College and that's
what's making it work so now the MIT
example of a blended curriculum it's
called the micro masters how many people
here have heard of a micro masters very
small number so I'll explain what a
micro masters is this is our
contribution to how to think about
blended learning at the curriculum level
so let me start with the definition
before I give you those high level
numbers so what is it MITx micro masters
it's four or five MIT graduate level
online classes master's level classes
and it's aimed at learners in the
workplace who are trying to advance
their careers and maybe they want to
then after they do this online work go
and get a master's degree at MIT MIT or
elsewhere or maybe not so a micro
masters is two things at the same time
first of all it's a valuable set of
online courses in for example supply
chain management that was our first
example so the classic story of a supply
chain masters supply chain management
micro master's learner they're 30 years
old on average they have one or maybe
even two degrees maybe they had a degree
in mechanical engineering or a degree in
chemistry or a degree in physics or
degree in philosophy and they got a job
and they're they've been working for a
while they discover you know I'm
actually what I what I'm doing is supply
chain management but I never learned
that so then they want to go and learn
the fundamentals of how supply chain
management works and they don't want to
leave their job at that moment and they
discover our online offerings
some of them after they finished the
four online courses in a proctored exam
and get the micro masters credential
might choose to go finish a master's
degree and if they come to MIT if we
admit them and they come to MIT then
they get credit for an entire semester
so the online work that they did before
coming counts as one semester of an MIT
master's degree at this moment out there
in the world there are one thousand
seven hundred and eighty people who have
finished a micro master's for MIT and
the first 40 of them actually as of
today this slide is out of date because
40 of them crossed Killian Court stage
last June and 36 more did so today so
that forty is now a seventy six we have
four of these micro masters being
offered a fifth will launch in the
spring the five topics of our first 5
micro masters of supply chain management
development economics data economics in
development policy that's the second
principles of manufacturing statistics
and data science and the one that
launches in 2020 is in finance and if
you look at some numbers the enroll
number again this is a number you should
not pay attention to because enrolling
is clicking a button but 31,000 courses
have been finished and certificates have
been earned this is about twenty
thousand people who've each done one or
more courses 1592 have finished the
micro masters in supply chain management
40 graduated on campus 36 more today for
the second micro masters that we
launched 2,300 courses completed hundred
and eighty-eight people finished the
whole program and the first 20 are
coming to MIT in January of 2020
principles of manufacturing and data
science
no one can yet have finished them
because the first run of the fourth
course in each is just happening right
now the people doing this are generally
have considerable prior education we
don't like the fact that only 20 percent
are women 28 percent are women and when
you finish a micro master's you don't
have to come to
my tea for a degree if you want to get a
master's degree there are now 27
universities in 18 countries with 85
different master's programs that will
admit you and give you credit for a
semester so the the value of the online
credential is being recognized by all
these different universities which are
all over the world so if you do the data
science one you can go to Uruguay and
get a masters degree in Uruguay if you
do the supply chain management one you
can go to Peru and get a masters degree
in Peru that's those are the South
American examples and then you can see
examples all around the world every
continent except Antarctica now has
universities that recognize mi t--'s
micro masters credentials so did the
students learn anything we can actually
figure that out because 40 of them so
this is the 40 who came to MIT and
graduated last year these are 40
students who came here and did what we
call a blended masters these 40 students
did for online five online courses first
proctored exams and only then were
selected and admitted to MIT came to MIT
and did the second half of the Masters
the on-campus way we can compare them to
the students who did a traditional
masters and took the same classes at the
same time last spring so we're comparing
40 students admitted in a new way to 40
students following a traditional path
taking the same classes at the same time
so the the blended students students
doing the blended path are a little bit
older and they have a little bit more
work experience and we survey them as
the semester draws to a close and ask
how well did you feel well prepared for
your classes and the students the
blended students the students who did
the micro masters felt better prepared
than the traditional students so they
took these classes online and then they
come here to MIT and they do the second
semester of their masters and they felt
in fact very well prepared they got
better grades these are the GPAs of the
new cohort of students was a little bit
higher than the GPAs of the traditional
cohort of students they got better
grades not by a lot but they got
slightly better grades
and to me the most interesting is when
we ask them both groups of students
about did you develop close
relationships with faculty are you
satisfied with your interactions with
faculty the new cohort of students more
likely to say they develop strong
relationships with faculty and are
slightly more satisfied with their
interactions with faculty and you ask
questions like do you see yourself as
part of a larger MIT community and it's
the students who did the online work
first who are more likely to see
themselves as part of a global MIT
community and so we did focus groups as
well as these surveys and what we heard
in the focus groups is that very it's
very interesting January of 2019 these
eighty students came together and each
group each half felt like they were that
they had had the real MIT experience 40
of them had had one semester at MIT and
so they of course were Bonavita a mighty
students and these were the newcomers
but the newcomers felt we've been
busting our tails for a year and a half
doing online courses while we were
working in our jobs that whole time
we've been seeing the MIT faculty in the
videos we've been engaging with them
through the discussion forum we've been
engaging with MIT for 15 months these
other 40 they've only been here for one
semester so actually each of these
groups felt connected to MIT and then
when they came together the new group
did slightly better on its grades so in
terms of thinking about what we do what
we see in the experience of these mem
ITX micro master's recipients validates
the MIT Ness of the online work it
validates the MIT quality of what all
our micro master's recipients have
learned from us online and so how have
we managed to do this it's because what
we offer online flows directly from what
we teach on campus which we think we do
a good job of I hope our alumni think we
do a good job of it and what we're
offering online is not an MIT education
you can't put an MIT education
online info because an MIT education
includes active discussion seminars
problem-solving practice makerspaces
project classes undergrad research and
much much more but everything we put
online is our components selected from
within an MIT education and they are the
components that we can take out from
within an MIT education and offer online
to MIT students and offer online to the
world and this experience with our micro
master's recipients validates the fact
that this is working and I will say just
this happened with Barton Rogers in the
1880s other places are copying us like
for example the Uruguayan's and San Jose
City College as I mentioned so that's my
second to last slide and I thought I
would end this slide with my motivations
why are we doing what we're doing well
why am I doing this
you know when Sanjay Sarma came and
asked me to be Dean white white I'm
white I say yes and so for me the
motivations come from three places one
is just watching how today's students at
MIT learn and realizing that by offering
them problem sets online offering them
flipping the classroom in the way that I
describe we are responding to the
students of today and teaching them in
the way that they are used to learning I
think of this through the lens of my
students at MIT I advise first-year
students every year I teach physics
majors I teach freshmen I also think of
it through the lens of my kids who are
14 and 16 now and if I watch how they
learn they don't learn the way I learned
because they have the internet and I
didn't and watching a house today
students engage and learn we have to do
this we have no choice if we want to
teach the students who come to us today
this is how we should be doing it and
then the second motivation is the
importance of lifelong learning just
looking at people in their careers
lifelong learning is it the question is
not is life long learning important
that's not the question the question is
what should MIT be doing
to support the lifelong learning of
people around the world including its
alumni and then the third comes just
from my core belief in the power of MIT
quality teaching and learning to make
the world a better place
I actually think about this again in a
personal way I think about well before I
do the personal example you know there's
300 million people out there who learned
something from OpenCourseWare there's
seven hundred and eighty thousand people
out there who have engaged seriously
with one of our online courses and
learned something from at least one
online course there's 1800 people out
there as of today who finished a micro
master's most of those people are not
people I will never meet
unlike the students in my classroom whom
I do meet but we have not offered them
the full MIT blended learning experience
but I think we've offered them something
that will help them make better lives
and better careers and make the world a
better place and the personal way I
think about this is I think about my
father in India who finished his
undergrad degree in 1950 and at that
moment in India had really no path
upwards if he had had something like a
micro masters to latch on to I think it
would have launched his career in a way
that there that I wasn't wasn't
available to him at that moment and so I
think about the people of today whom I
will never meet but who will make better
lives and better careers using the tools
that we are providing I thought I would
end with just two discussion questions
for you the alumni of MIT and this is
two different variants of how can you as
alumni benefit from and enhance our
efforts so how can you benefit well I'd
like to ask you how can we better engage
alumni in digital learning in in support
of your lifelong learning needs we are
thinking of offering discounts and in
particular we're thinking of making all
of our mitx courses free to all MIT
alumni for the first two years after
they graduate so that they can earn
credentials in addition to just
auditing the courses and I'm very
curious what how alumni are what might
be interested in getting involved we
have community TAS and many of our
courses this is a volunteer role in
which learners who took the course last
year engage as TAS this year just
because they want to
is this a role in which alumni can serve
as volunteers for the Institute or are
there others and I thought I would end
after my sort of personal closing with
these questions for you thank you and
I've been asked to ask people to use the
microphones in the aisle because that
the Q&A will be recorded also so I see
your hand could you use the microphone
and let me also ask please introduce
yourself briefly in whatever way you
choose so um I'm Martina voidism class
of 79 and my CTO in a company my current
venture is a is a grad I mean have
studied what he knows and he credits his
capacity to to MIT learning so that this
opened my eyes because this is one of
the smartest develop person I know and
and I see there is a huge potential but
I wonder what your limitations are and
how what is it exactly the question that
you are Stas is the question to you I I
the other thing that I do is I am at the
educational counselor and I meet I pick
I see these students these wonderful
students I see every year and they sit
in front of me and they fascinate me and
they don't get it know so um how can we
you know how can we blow up the walls
you know and take
in a take MIT to the world it's I mean
the numbers that you show are
interesting but but you know you how
does this scale to you know ten times a
hundred times a thousand times great how
do we need to do so so I can give
multiple answers to that question let me
let me try to so one is that I D nitride
to engage with other institutions
including the one in Uruguay including
the one in San Jose those are the ones I
chose to put on slides but many others I
think a big part of how we can scale is
to have educational institutions that
know their students and know how to
teach their students know their level
know their trajectory to use online
content that comes from whether it's MIT
or Berkeley or elsewhere and to blend
that into the learning that they offer I
think there are many places where
something that we can offer would add to
the education that they can offer and
and so that's one scaling answer the one
the example you mentioned as an
educational counselor there's to me a
real challenge that I don't think I have
a good answer to yet and that is a lot
of our intro classes I think are
outstanding for the best high school
students the kinds of high school
students who you will be meeting with in
this role and and what's what what are
the ways you know we as MIT we look if
I'm not Stewie I'm not the director of
admissions
I think if MIT if Stu schmell as
director of MIT admissions said hey if
you want to come to MIT we want you to
take MIT online courses I think that
would be a complete and utter disaster
because the mi t--'s of the world are
already causing so much stress in the
high school population I'm the I'm the
parent of two high school students if
the mi t--'s of the world said if you
want to get into a place like MIT in
addition to doing all the high school
stuff you got to take MIT online courses
that would be a complete that would be
it that would be you know
who would never say that that would that
would be a really bad so but on the
other hand I also think that for many
high school students if they want to
learn calculus in it it would be great
if in addition to whatever they have
from their teacher in their high school
they took our 1801 X I think it would
really help how they learn calculus
because I think it's MIT quality so one
question I can ask you is is how we
should how can we send a message out to
the world that we've produced a resource
or in the middle of we're in the process
of producing a resource that should be
of great value to high school students
who to a subset of high school students
not to every single high school student
without sending an unhealthy message
that is not our intention and I don't
have a good answer for that actually so
I'm curious as an educational counselor
if you can help with that I'd be I'd be
open to thinking about how to send that
message both how to phrase it and how to
deliver it at the professional level so
at the micro masters level I think we
have the model our challenge is to build
more micro masters we have built for
we're building a fifth I'm in
conversations with faculty who are
potentially interested in building
several more if you just look at our
history we've built one a year with
first one was in 2016 fifth one is gonna
be in 2020 that's one a year on average
I think we'll be building one new micro
masters per year on an average for a
good many a good number more years you
have to find the sweet spot in terms of
I don't think I'm a theoretical
physicist we're never going to do micro
masters in theoretical physics there's
not a population of working people who
are in their jobs who are going to
advance their careers by doing
theoretical physics so with for
theoretical physics you think about the
high school students you think about the
undergrads at all the institutions where
we can teach more quantum mechanics in a
way that many universities cannot so you
free associating off your question but
if you think about Barton's course MIT
offers a three-course sequence in
quantum mechanics the only other
university in the United States with
three are three undergrad courses in
quantum mechanics is Caltech and if you
finish those three undergrad courses in
the quantum mechanics all of which we
have online now courtesy Barton you can
take two courses in quantum information
and quantum computing that I Krong Seth
Floyd Aaron Harrow and Peter shor worked
on building that's a great way of adding
to the education of you know one or two
or three physics majors at each of a
thousand universities so how do we get
that word out at the at the professional
at the micro master's level I think we
have a good model but we wouldn't use
that for quantum mechanics we'd use that
for finance as the next one we've done
it for supply chain management
manufacturing data economics develop
policy maybe I won't share which other
topics I'm talking with faculty about
but I'm not talking with the faculty who
teach quantum mechanics I'm talking with
the faculty who teach masters level
content that would be right for the kind
of person I'm describing so we're trying
to find the right mode of using these
new tools and technologies that works
for lifelong learning at the Masters
level for people who are seeking to
upskill that's one mode expanding upon
what you can learn as an undergraduate
using Barton's quantum mechanics classes
that's another mode and then the one
which actually I don't think we have the
found the right way don't think we've
found the right framing to is-is-is how
to reach high school students in a way
that doesn't constitute MIT further I
mean have so having seen a little bit of
my oldest son is now a sophomore in high
school but certainly through kids of
friends having seen the high school
experience and the applying to
university experience it's a it's nuts
and and so I'm really conscious of
not wanting to MIT not sending messages
that make that make that experience
worse but at the same time I think we
have something that that should be a
great tool for learning for many high
school students and and gee maybe you
can help me hi I'm Jeff I'm class of
1999 classic which story in 1999 math
course 18 so Reid Hoffman the founder of
LinkedIn has a book called the startup
of you and in this book there's a
chapter which title drew my eye it said
what you know is who you know my first
reaction is oh that's interesting and my
second reaction having read it was you
evil bastard you because it seemed to me
that was about it was told this story
about here's my friend who's awesome
her boss Esther something really hard
and she just knew this Harvard professor
that knew all the answers and got the
answers from her friend and like you
know success no real sense of like and
you know the Harvard got professor got
paid or anything like that and you know
I think of MIT might so my third
reaction to this was I finally
understood what he was getting at when I
heard an NPR radio interview with him on
I think it was how I built this
interviewed him and the thing that I got
when he told his story himself is the
thing that he grew out he these people
that he built his success with and he
who that informed this point of view
were genuinely his friends and
colleagues they weren't people who he
was out to sort of scam so if we think
of what you know as who you know is the
definition of learning as falling under
that bigger umbrella what what holes
might there be left to fill I just free
associate if three things that I can
throw out there one is you know the guy
who founded Dropbox you know he didn't
even graduate here he showed up and he
like you Athena AFS and he's like why
doesn't everybody have this and he
brought a shitty version for the masses
and it's like now we have this right
that seems like maybe something that you
know we could we could learn from you
know I think of
I found sometimes certain of the
conference's that I attend every once in
a while some one of them will offer you
know I hallway only track don't go to
the top you know the talks but just show
up in the hallway and just talk to the
people are there
I think we're filling a pretty good are
there a lot of really good alumni local
chapters that are filling that kind of
niche like I live in Seattle and they
put on just great events out there but I
wonder you know like here's an example
where I feel like there's a whole part
of this like experience that I had
learning and and studying with my peers
when I was here was you know on the
computer so it was Zephyr you know you
would sit there and you'd suffer the
person sitting in the chair right right
next to it right and like there's
totally software for this and actually
Sippy has the only there's a software
called matter most they sippy has the
only installation on the MIT II do
domain I just out of curiosity just look
for it and joined it while you were
giving your talk here and the thing is
is that like I put in any verification
email that was like alumni MIT I could
thick I could do an installation of that
and just filter an alumni to MIT and say
now everyone who wants to talk to other
people who are you know verified as
alumni MIT can do that does that make a
difference for these learnings that are
I think of small learnings I think of
the reading group size learnings there's
no course in the world so so well there
are many look there are many things I
can threads in what you just said that I
can I can pick out of what you said and
and amplify certainly certainly there
are if you if you think about ways to
improve engagement online so the
discussion forum that we use the EDX
discussion forum could you know one of
the things that EDX is planning to build
out is some of the tools that are that
you're talking about it I don't mean the
specific tools but tools that would
allow small groups within a course to
create discussion section sections we do
that on campus all the time right we do
that on campus all the time that's an
example of something which I would like
to see
at X building out as a component of its
platform and so what day it's it's on
it's on their roadmap there was another
thing that you asked about implicitly
which is how does that mighty get paid
that came that was a different thing in
your in your remark so the key to that
actually is that we have this whole
suite so they're they're the how does
MIT get paid is different for the
different parts we know what MIT how to
fund research its research is funded by
a whole variety of ways of getting
sponsored research funding
Jameel world education lab is a
membership organization that Uruguayan
University has joined the Jameel World
Education lab there's a there's a
membership fee and they're joining
because in joining that engages them
with us in a way that allows us to help
them make their education better MITx
i the the certificates people people pay
a space fee that ranges between $50 and
$300 per course for those certificates
that brings in revenue these
professional IDI offerings that I
mentioned these boot camps these are for
aimed at think of it as mid-level
executives who are interested in
entrepreneurship this is a one-week
educational intense educational
experience that costs more than six
thousand dollars so that brings of
course it it it also to deliver an
experience like that as a considerable
effort but it does bring in revenue when
you when you add up all of this Owen I
should say because what we are doing
part of what we're doing is improving
how we teach MIT students we get a piece
of budget from the standard MIT budget
from what at MIT is called the GI be the
general institute budget we get a piece
of the of standard MIT budget because
part of what we do is helping to teach
MIT students better when you act when
you add this all up the office of open
learning is
from a financial point of view a highly
viable concern let me just put it that
way I don't want to I don't want to do
actual budget numbers but if you pick
any one piece of it you know certainly
if I look at MIT X alone by itself and
you ask about the cost of building the
online courses versus the revenue from
the certificates we spend much more on
building the courses that we get from
certificates but what we get from those
online courses is much more than revenue
we get impact we get reach we get return
we get yield on undergrad admissions we
get micro masters learners coming here
to finish a master's degree we get all
kinds of we get all kinds of value in
addition to the return but then you look
at these professional IDI offerings and
these professional and offerings really
do generate revenue and so when you add
it when you add it all up MIT is doing
very well and the key to this if I pick
one person that Sanjay Sarma Sanjay is
the vice president for open learning he
leads the whole effort and I think he's
the one who's realized and has built
over the course of the last six years
each of these with the exception of
OpenCourseWare each of these is seven
years or less old so OpenCourseWare was
18 years old everything else on this
slide is 7 or less years old and it's
Sanjay who's realized that realized that
what we need is there's not one you know
you you don't just build MIT X and and
that's that's that's gonna do everything
you don't just do boot camps and that's
gonna do everything you don't just do
research and that's gonna do everything
that what we need is a suite like this
and I mean if I if I if I speak a little
bit about Sanjay he before he started
this he has started a number of
companies he's a MIT faculty member
who's also an entrepreneur so he has
experience in starting things from
nothing and turning them into something
I'm a theoretical physicist I was the
associate head of the physics department
I was the chair of the MIT faculty I've
never started anything from zero but I
know how mighty works and I know how to
run things in a way that
grow them nourish them support them
expand them augment them and to do so in
a way that builds is consistent with MIT
s values and builds its reputation and
impact so that's that's what I know how
to do but I've never started something
from nothing and and all of this is
relatively new except OpenCourseWare
which is I don't if you consider 18
years old new or not everything here
it's it's the package together that's
working from a financial point of view
that's that's the that's the answer to
your financial question
so I'm gonna maybe follow a little bit
on to what Jeff was talking about
I'm Scott Holmes class of 1979 former
Lerman learning strategist now I'm a
program manager at DARPA ah so if we go
back to the other slide you showed the
yeah forward to the discussion I'm
looking at this and I'm looking at the
course where the courses they're a
little bit there like courses and
they're a little bit like hammers and
they you know you know though it's all
about the only tool you have is a hammer
everything every problem looks like a
nail
yes what I'm not seeing is the smaller
things great the things that I think
back to what I learned at MIT yeah and
the great was it I learned in the
courses yeah and there were a lot of
other things that I learned that we're
not in the courses so there's a lot of
other things aren't there and that's an
area where I think the alumni can really
contribute because there's a lot of
things that we come out we learn and we
know in the real working world that
we're never in courses so there's
opportunity there yes micro things
absolutely how can we there's alumni
create those things and make them
available and get feedback on them and
I'm also not seeing the the drive from
the learners what do they want so well
so I okay so these are there are
multiple really good questions in what
you just said so one of the I didn't
mention it when I was on the slide but
one of the things that we're doing is is
we're in the in the discovery phase if
designing where are we here of designing
a new platform for OpenCourseWare and
one of the motivations for that actually
is search is search and discovery so
that you can within within
OpenCourseWare there are many of those
nuggets but those nuggets are buried as
parts of a course and and how do you
find the Nugget if what you're
interested in is the particular nugget
as opposed to the whole course that's
one of the drivers for
are thinking about building a new
platform a new platform underneath those
open courseware you can ask similar
questions for MIT X and you can also ask
about just making smaller modules and we
do make smaller modules we don't make
everything some of our hammers are
smaller hammers they may still be
hammers and but I have to be careful
because you know a big part of what
makes what we offer valuable is the
connection to how we teach on campus and
the easiest way of seeing that this is
connected on on campus teaching is to
say well on campus we have 1801 and this
is 1801 X but now Gen French and and
David garrison and the people who built
1801 X the online calculus course
divided it into three modules so it's
three smaller hammers but I think that's
only the beginning we are talking on
OpenCourseWare about podcasts an example
of a small non course like object where
we are thinking about all the stuff that
faculty have done residentially which
you can't see many of it is much smaller
it might be at the one problem set level
it might be at the I'll give an example
with a named Ric dan Houser who teaches
organic chemistry he's made MITx style
video reviews for each of his tests and
that's it it's not an entire course it's
just the test reviews but still so you
there are lots of smaller things out
there the question is how to curate them
and present them in a way that's
searchable in a value and event and then
a value to whom so we this is actually
something that Daniel is not there
anymore Daniel who used to be sitting
right up there who is the senior
learning systems designer in my office
spends a decent fraction of his day
thinking about how to engage alumni and
building this bar are things that
actually I had not been thinking about
and I'd be happy to talk with you about
that offline we've we've we've been
thinking a lot about the notion of
smaller nuggets in the context of the
things that we already have either
produced for residential purposes or are
hiding within OpenCourseWare or hiding
within MIT X but I've not been thinking
about this from the perspective of
engaging our alumni be curious to talk
with you more we'll take one last one
yes my name my name is Mark Baker class
of 69 and I've just mentioned to two
areas and I get again I'm not certain
how they what might fit in but we much
older alumni most of us don't work
anymore for our current companies and a
number of my colleagues I went to school
with our professors from prestigious
universities that have retired that
they're considered experts in their
field yes they did they didn't teach at
MIT they may they took classes here in
graduated but so their might and they
have we have time yeah whereas many
people working in the field don't have
the luxury of spending time and I'm
certain that these classes to put them
together the instructor has to commit a
lot of time to do that yeah there may be
an opportunity there's absolutely and so
so what was your field Britain what was
your own field Oh architecture and
engineering okay completely different
degrees Electrical Engineering and
architecture okay so I'm not sure I've a
specific example for architecture for
electrical engineering we could probably
come up with a specific example in it
but so the the what you're saying
reminds me of the following a challenge
and I think we know how we have ways of
overcoming this is not a this is not a
big obstacle but it's a it's a challenge
and that is you're you you build an
online course and the first time you run
it the faculty member is incredibly
engaged and the second time you run it
they in fact make a bunch of
improvements based on the experience of
the first time but now you're at the
third run and the faculty member would
just like to press play but but you need
someone in the discussion forum
answering questions and and and leading
that discussion now okay so maybe it's
an MI GTA but maybe there's a better
answer than an RMIT TA and there's
actually a startup company called edify
which their their business model is to
try to solve this problem for not just
for MIT but for other universities that
are building online courses and their
idea is to find retired faculty they vet
them check the resumes vet them they
interview them they do the HR part they
hire them and then they present them to
the MIT faculty member and say look this
is the person that we have found who
could run your course who could answer
questions in your course and the MIT
professor maybe interviews them signs
them up and then four runs three four
five six that person is the person in
the discussion forum and maybe the
faculty member pops into the forum a
couple of times in the semester and what
I hear you saying is that this might be
a great role perhaps at the volunteer
level the the MIT alum may not be
thinking about being hired through edify
they might be thinking about this at the
volunteer level phone in a volunteer way
and I can easily imagine many MIT
faculty who build courses really loving
the idea of an MIT alum who was from
that field playing that role it I think
it's a matter of finding and making the
connections I can easily imagine this
working really well if we could make the
right right connections and in a sense
edify is trying to do this but not from
a perspective of thinking about the MIT
alumni network so there's there's a role
there thank you so thank you all very
much please come up and if you'd like to
get our newsletter sign one of these
sheets and Yvonne and Megan and Lana and
I can take further questions but I'm
gonna turn the my
run off and thank you all for coming
[Applause]